the last week of my scooter Odyssey has
started I have to step on it if I'm
going to make it to my destination in 80
days but the steep climb here isn't
making it easy
the end of my tour is not far away
anymore but the Black Forest is another
obstacle however this mountain range
rises up to almost 1500 meters and is
therefore not Sandford a scooter
compatible the Black Forest lies exactly
2197 kilometers and 73 days from my
destination Halden vaanga ik in the far
south is known for the black forest a
tool for the boneheads and for the
cuckoo clock and the largest cuckoo
clock in the world is right yeah this
cuckoo clock near kleeberg is so big at
a height of more than 15 meters that you
can comfortably walk in it it's a
replica of a traditional black forest
cuckoo clock on a scale of sixty to one
so its individual components are also
big and heavy the clock measures four
and a half meters by four and a half
meters and weighs six tons the pendulum
is eight meters long and weighs 100
kilos and even the cuckoo tips the
scales at a hefty 150 Ralf a blow owns
the world's biggest cuckoo clock what
purpose does a cuckoo clock serve
compared to an ordinary clock Black
Forest cuckoo clocks have nothing in
common with ordinary clocks they are
very special because of the beautiful
carvings and the call of the cuckoo
embodies the Black Forest
I've heard there's another world's
biggest cuckoo clock how many world's
biggest are there of course there can
only be one but the other one is
actually not far from here in Shona it
used to hold the record as the world's
biggest cuckoo clock
but we've broken that many times over
with our giant clock 150,000 cuckoo
clocks are made in Germany every year
most are exported abroad most go to the
US but they are hidden China as well and
brand-new models are nurturing hopes
that a decline in sales can be stopped a
well cared-for cuckoo clock has a life
expectancy of about 30 years it's
incredible huge we Germans do seem to
love superlatives I'm scooting on past
the next superlative supposedly the
highest waterfall in Germany I'm heading
for show now where I read world's
biggest cuckoo clock now that's one
superlative too many you're the proof we
Germans won't do with one largest cuckoo
clock in the world we need two of them
and this world's original biggest cuckoo
clock is on a scale of 50 to one it's
three meters 60 long three meters 10
wide and a meter deep
yosef dolls this man in traditional
clockmakers garb built it in 1980 this
is the original world's biggest back
there I just saw the world's biggest
what's the difference between this is
the first original world's biggest
cuckoo clock I made it by hand
okay one is the first world's biggest
and the other is the current world's
biggest what if I were to build the last
world's biggest cuckoo clock would you
accept me into the world's biggest group
yes we'd accept you as the last world's
biggest there wouldn't be a problem
that's very kind of you Thanks as I've
said before Germany has a lot of
superlatives but it's worth looking more
closely I might trip downhill I see the
world's biggest black forest hat and
probably the world's largest toadstool
then it's on through the Black Forest
towards my destination
you